so I'm gonna recursively define an
arithmetic sequence so we're gonna say
that the eighth term of the sequence is
equal to the I minus one term of the
secant sequence plus 11 plus 11
so the ithe so each term is going to be
11 more than the term before it
now we have to establish a base case
here and so we're gonna say that the
first term of our arithmetic sequence is
going to be equal to 4
so given this recursive definition of
our arithmetic sequence right over here
what I challenge you to do is to find
the first 600 find the sum of the first
650 terms of the sequence then write
that down to find the sum of first 650
terms of the sequence of this arithmetic
sequence that we have just defined and
like always pause the video and see if
you can work that out
alright so how can we think about this
well certainly in many videos we gave
our intuition for the the sum of an
arithmetic sequence and we came up with
a formula for evaluating in a sum of an
arithmetic sequence which we'd call an
arithmetic series and that sum of the
first n terms is going to be the first
term plus the last term over 2 so really
the average of the first and the last
term's times the number of terms we have
and this is only the case when it's an
arithmetic but it's an arithmetic series
where each term that we're adding is a
fixed amount larger or less than the
term before it early we have a fixed
difference so what about this one right
over here what is what is the first and
the last term going to be and what is
our n well we know that n is 650 we know
that n is 650 and we know what the first
term is going to be the first term is
going to be 4 but we need to figure out
what the nth term is what is the or we
need to figure out what the 650th
term is going to be well let's think
about this a little bit
so this is going to be for taking the
sum it's going to be four plus the next
term this the the second term so if a
sub two is going to be a sub one plus
eleven so it's going to be four plus 11
which is 15 we're going to add 11 which
is going to get us to 26 and we're going
to keep a lot adding 11 now how many
times are we going to add 11 well to get
to the second term we add 11 once to get
to the third term we add 11 twice to go
so to get to the six hundred and
fiftieth term so plus so this is a sub
650 a sub 650 we're going to have to add
11 look to get to the second term we
added 11 once third term add 11 twice so
to get to the six hundred and fiftieth
term we are going to add 11 we're going
to add 11 650 minus one times or six
hundred and forty nine times notice to
get to each term to get to the first
term you added one minus one
you had an 11 1 minus one times you
added 11 0 times you start with the four
I didn't add 11 at all then the second
term you at 11 once third term you add
11 twice fort term you add 11 three
times 650th term you at 11 649 times and
so if you add 11 649 times what do you
get so four plus six hundred 49 times 11
is going to be equal to I'll get my
calculator out for this so this is going
to be equal to six 49 times 11 is equal
to now plus four is equal to seven
thousand 143 seven thousand 143 so
that's the six hundred and fiftieth term
seven thousand one hundred and forty
three and so now we can just evaluate
this so we'll get the calculator out for
that so we have seven thousand 143 plus
four plus the first term plus four is
equal to that we're gonna divide by two
so divide by two
it gets us three thousand five hundred
seventy three point five we're gonna
multiply that times six hundred fifty
that's how many terms we have times six
hundred fifty is equal to that's a
pretty large number it's going to be
equal to two million three hundred
twenty two thousand seven hundred and
seventy-five two million three hundred
twenty two thousand seven hundred
seventy five so I already forgot it
three million I have to have a I have
trouble remembering things when I take
it off my screen all right two million
three hundred two million three hundred
twenty two thousand seven hundred and
seventy-five I'm glad I had a calculator
at hand for that one but you couldn't do
it by hand I always encourage you to it
never hurts to practice the arithmetic